all righty let's go right started you
started what's up fool what's a full
podcast welcome everybody to the what's
a full podcast we have Row 3 with Torres
right here coast host of the year of the
nine oh nine nine five one can't bonito
huh yeah it changed the show the OC OC
mo some fool showed up to the party at
OC and then no they took a gun out and
then a girl's eye they must be from the
909 we got Tom Petty in the house Andy
Samberg right here okay okay I mean any
summer I'm with Aries on the Jew in the
jerk the oh yeah and the myth the legend
he really came on each other like hey we
know I was here today actually
oh my god it's fine yeah our podcast is
still in the infancy stage we're not
even two years or almost two years old
two years eighty Sochi boy 100 podcast I
we gotta celebrate I guess yeah live so
that's the the Jew in the jerks peers in
Steinberg aka
the Jew in the jerk uh you know what man
I was you know he was showing up to a
lot of the comedy clubs cheerleader one
in the California area Brea on Tahoe
Irvine I know technology you kept going
up and uh you know one thing led to
another we started talking and I let him
in initiated it's funny though because
like there's a lot of hangers on all the
time trying you know little flies yeah
and they don't know she ain't gonna
benefit you anything and finally
somebody cracked your little uh I had
jokes your uh
you dungeon yeah yeah hey Joe borrowed
bro would he screwed my pad isn't my
patty
so what to his pad he lived like in a
garage back house with someone else and
we're there man just eating like a kiss
of the year it hitting small bows and a
drive-by shooting right outside you
smoke weed yeah [ __ ] drive-by shooting
right on Central and I remember I
recorded he was talking about it what
happened bro bro
it was douche douche you know people in
the hood only donor describe exactly the
some of the bullets perfect sound
effects part it's from a zombie omocha
had a silencer yeah Ozzy is good morning
baby somebody always know this query
like but he never tell that story to the
cars later cut it stitches you know he
can't talk to the Popo get lumped up but
yeah if another neighborhood he's
[ __ ] doing here how puppet
reenactments go II know that you have a
weird people growing out like carrot
icky I didn't really started comedy so
very young yeah bro bro I was I saw a
video of you who I'm daring something
somebody busted out the old deaf chance
bro well I Steven I paid nobody know I
bought I bought the collection of things
baby yeah so it means you started comedy
a 14th that good I don't know how good I
was playing okay new rising like that
time oh yeah dice for that [ __ ] with a
starter put the starter pack for anybody
to do sounds well I was you know I was
on my little Eddie Murphy [ __ ] you saw I
had my leather gloves and yeah I wasn't
gonna wear all of the suit that would've
made it too obvious so I stuck with the
all denim and then I just kind of
tricked out with the leather gloves a
little bit yes what I was going through
my Eddie Murphy phase was that Eddie
Murphy and dice uh Eddie dies huh yeah
yeah yeah and you know what it's funny
cuz I mean the guy who does sums to
perfection right here bro I would love
to hear it yeah I wish it here with
Steinberg ring
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] scientist name
from through a date out there so
crazy-ass name you grew up with and
they're like where you are at
Joey actually didn't man TV man he
played [ __ ] bompensiero on the MADtv
sketch we did The Sopranos on the PAX
Network yeah so yeah he's he actually
came through a couple times man oh wait
not Andy she started with you're 16
years old yes for that 4000 that like
cuz you're like a young kid man seen big
shots bro you know what man I came up
with a lot of the dudes in the jersey
new york area Bill Bellamy hamburger
Jones and a burger and a lot of
[ __ ] that didn't everybody
didn't Gretchen is it really yeah really
yeah hamburger I would never have known
yeah man I saw her somewhere he was very
comedian with hamburger yeah I never
would have known that but yeah we all
came up together man and me and Bill was
kind of the other the only dudes from
New Jersey New York area too kind of
move on so to speak so yeah man it just
it's surreal cuz you look back at those
old Def Jam's and you could see
everybody's newness yeah like we had
some of those ticks you know of
nervousness like bill would say a
hundred times yo that's crazy right
every couple words yo that's crazy right
you know we all had our little things
and now when you look back at it from
then till now it's like we all kind of
like jazz musicians now we just kind of
flow now it's not so much that nervous
energy you know I mean you're sure the
first time you wind up a diphthong Ellen
cleghorne Raj myself and I can't
remember the last dude's name you better
get our board from what made up cuz I'd
like to run the SNL and she disappeared
Wow I thought she all right I thought
she passed away I may be wrong yeah I
think you know I'm thinking out Danitra
Vance who was on SNL for only one season
before one does she's taking a deep
breath right now everybody's pulling on
like a battery but Jim Carr we're late I
remember - yeah he was Doris Day
I thought she'd been going that security
check oh my god
did she wanted no funeral no flowers no
nothing brought you what nothing bro she
left her money all the animal projects
animal charities female I wouldn't be a
bird I want no I want no celebration you
know just ashes and I want everybody to
grab ashes and just throw people faces
like that I can I roll yours up in smoke
oh yeah I want to see what Philippe
tastes like going down and that's great
that didn't come out you know that big
ass cast me everybody holding it yeah
bad how no Casio bro
if you see that video matter that they
buried a Puerto Rican guy in Puerto Rico
but his wake he was standing up mmm that
the hell is did in the old cowboy days
oh yeah they really know standing up for
those are varmints right buddy by I
guess they had a wig it would haven't
wait to make sure that person was really
dead
cuz I build you sure but again they were
not laid down though they were standing
up right so at the funeral this Puerto
Rican guy was just standing there like
this and his homies are passing by no
job where they give it a face bomb yeah
but they had sunglasses on that food
yeah Chris I want to ask some Hispanic
questions díganos um somebody recently
had us on our podcast who's the funniest
latin comedian do you think and and
listen we not play with a camera
nobody's we got some big teachers either
go run and tell bro he said you all
right I said you and nikeyra
yeah absolutely Guerra I mean you're
appeared shot by Willie Barcena yeah
Isis the nicest Latino or nice the
comedian nice like Latino comedian you
mean who's famous rip a room Paul
Rodriguez who Paul Rodriguez at one time
in Hawaii was [ __ ] on fire last year
yeah really yeah yeah put yourself in an
arrow in that list
I didn't this fools gathered up with
those fools I need to be a top 50 Latino
comedian in every row of 39 bro your
remedies less I'll join Medea banette
Modena number on the top 10 at the time
was the Portuguese Joe Lopez
column and see Apollo Francisco called
me see it was tailored a grown and
gradual Rondo and then a bunch of people
bunch of coach the clash and then a
bunch of other people there
in the body with our 49 like one from
the 49 and only one person came up
without a 1999 yeah nobody makes these
lists any more fairly any Latinos on the
top ten comedians you should watch any
more like Marcella shows up every once
no one yeah here's my second question
when that whole public Francisco would
say the funniest still he made me laugh
that much like a rip a room apart you
know one city I think when he's not like
whatever's happening with him but when
he's on he's [ __ ] on stills the
audience who see the stay back six times
still laugh they don't give a [ __ ] I
can't [ __ ] cuz I've heard people talk
to you about that but you know whatever
it is I [ __ ] seen that full rip it up
I see them I see part of drinkers
working bro within a show and then it
being a daytime you know I didn't beat
it outside broad at this big old music
fair war was late
yeah Marlo are these Latino lowrider
acts and apology goes up first and I'm
like watching them man that fool just
took the microphone and he started
walking around the audience you know why
and finish he's a 25 minute history
history is 25 minutes instead of like
being on stage complaining bro he just
sort of walked around I didn't like
[ __ ] Oprah but start asking questions
saw his time got off the [ __ ] stage
see you good night a good look for a hot
ghost when that Carlos Mencia [ __ ] went
down did you feel a certain kind of way
I felt like a shame man that I never got
my job stolen from do I suck in what
were to go away I mean I'm just in a
sense like you know the whole thing
about him not really being Mexican and I
thought the type of thing like you know
I'm saying limey did you still see him
as yo this is a bad mother [ __ ]
comedian or did you change oh I saw that
fool perforce he was a ripper
because there's a lot of [ __ ]
that's still - and they don't get called
out
now and people say all that bad [ __ ]
about me right but I mean there's
[ __ ] that we're doing it on TV
shows and they don't [ __ ] get blasted
by the guy that blasted on him right
there's a lot of [ __ ] you know you know
to sort of [ __ ] on it people talk to you
all he's a Honduran or whatever the [ __ ]
but dude he grew up in the MonaVie I
projects he's raised by a Mexican mom
and he's right representing for Mexicans
but whatever you want to say I mean I
mean I still got mad respect for him I
suppose I've seen him rip two and a half
hours before just like with nothing just
just having a good time having fun not
[ __ ] just being him but it's cool to
say he's a thief and everybody's know
circles and still around
yeah that's think he's still suing
selling out two weeks of [ __ ] two
weekends of [ __ ] yeah it's funny I
always tell people man like you know
everybody every comic has a congregation
and even when you said people that go
see Pablo and they've seen it six times
how many times you seen your favorite
movie right yeah bounce key and one
thing I felt about Carlos though was his
openers didn't have his back dawg and
then like threw him under the bus after
all that [ __ ] heart and I've heard
[ __ ] [ __ ] talking [ __ ] about
like his his opener stole jokes from
other [ __ ] and gave him to him
and he was actually that happens to
writers on TV show which happens a lot
of TV shows when you're in the room and
you need to come up with a joke as a
staff writer you'll pull from anybody do
you think do you think in terms of
culturals cultures what's harder white
crowds or Latino crowds only reason why
I asked that is because I think Latinos
and blacks are so similar and the way we
respond to humor sometimes so that's why
I'm asking you that cuz I have an answer
for that from my side of things I think
it's a Latino crowd you know crow you
don't get cuz they're quiet dog they're
nautical you like brothers and that's
like Mike Rousey really but white crowds
is different you can like [ __ ] at
least [ __ ] you know they'll give you
a pat on the back I like it white
brother chuckle and then at the end of
the show you killed it yeah do you a
left hard but they're like ha when you
say Latino crowds are quiet what do you
mean they don't really they don't heckle
you like there's waiting for you to keep
[ __ ] us you know the only heck who
you after they know who you're after
you're famous don't talk to your host
show
and what they love me we all have your
own know they would challenge your wife
[ __ ] and don't heckle you betcha do it I
just do a show in Montebello California
I was a Latino Mexican crowd always and
as I got better the comedian that
audience got better heckling oh hell
yeah
so once I had a 25-minute instead these
guys were [ __ ] telling a good [ __ ]
head cause that was a paid crowd yeah
they're paying five bucks to get it was
a show we had a light on a block [ __ ] I
saw careers end up there
what's your butcher host
you know I always say uh I know this
white crowd applaud effort
like if a comic come up don't really say
unfunny but he put a lot of energy in
the joke well he goes on a profanity
filled rant white people simultaneously
go and I go [ __ ] don't give a [ __ ]
about effort first of all we made you
baby
in this [ __ ] then you forced us
to buy two drinks [ __ ] want results we
treat jokes like a buffet haha next joke
you don't build no points man well you
know and I kind of felt like Latino
crowds might be the same way that's true
like you're just as good as your last
joke was yeah yeah I think that's true
when you're up there the only time I've
ever played a majority heavy Latin crowd
as I forget what radio station used to
do it but they used to do the big
festival up north Hey outside : yeah
some of them wildlands he knows and
there be wow there's a [ __ ] you
tell these [ __ ] got felonies
so you like you know and then let you
know you did a big show there was
Chappelle right in the center lane no no
no no I did I did the garden with Tracy
Morgan
Oh in New York I think you're on that
show too in New York yeah with meet Bill
Bellamy and Dean Edwards and okay that's
right Dean Edwards it was a deer a Tracy
Morgan with hosted yeah it was in yeah
holy [ __ ] I wound up on the set where
the [ __ ] I won't have to look out with a
hat talk about beer to talk about monkey
Ricky no young comic no car me but I
follow a black girl
CEO Roxy yeah [ __ ] a big afro nominees
in what's up all those nominees that was
cool after that show I got to tour with
um my care for the whole year no you
just did like four months for mother to
Ross four months in a row yeah I was
like January to April you tell my
stories question cuz I'm curious about
Latin life go for our boy how come black
women we're prom dresses to the
laundromat those laundry because those
are of them immigrants you had your turn
cuz I have a chocolate that are my
immigrants you know we were poor we
didn't know man we don't know styles you
know cuz I think my father would our
Latino dads don't plan [ __ ] like a were
to go to zoo where this so we were in a
church another southern man but my
wearing [ __ ] wedges at Disneyland
[ __ ] so I just a surprise attack you
know that we'd be having a wedding bro
that's what the wedding my Dennis Taylor
who takes to [ __ ] Magic Mountain is
[ __ ] so we look like [ __ ] though the
problems at the [ __ ] Magic Mountain
but that face is what it is man we don't
and cuz I'm from New York so I grew up
in Manhattan and I'm and then coming out
to LA I didn't know that how come
Porto Ricans and Mexicans beef so much
well for the hate each other I hate each
other
no no it's a hatred dude we don't like
Trinidad de la hoya it was a hatred
there
yeah Porto Ricans in LA to hate that
Bush we replace it with solid Orioles
only here I've seen that before Porto
Ricans play Mexicans and movies
you mean just tell the difference yeah
yeah oh yeah okay that's coming from I
mean Lucas Lucas Selena that was JLo you
know [ __ ] boys brother in a la Bamba
is [ __ ] what's-his-name
Oh Richie Lou Diamond Phillips no the
blue diamond field yeah you some rallies
but nobody got as mad at him for
planning me know if they did a tailor
for playing on Mexican rice all I ever
hear is it's almost like Porter Wiggins
look down on Mexicans they may try but
it's like you break Bowser older
cultural norms to really there's not
like [ __ ] like new generation don't
carry on all that [ __ ] but I don't
car everybody wants your Spanish speak
you can hate on anybody [ __ ] human
nature I'm riled I believe car - yeah my
like is it depend like what generation I
mind that generation of the are man
those are caribbean Latino they don't
even count
oh god it's amazing to find out even
though you're the same you're not the
same but you're not for the same we want
you be my special needs bill talks about
that I say like about there's no white
people in the room and no black people
in the room
[ __ ] Mexico will stop being racist it
again other Mexicans write about class
right but in the end it's about class
don't go it's about class here [ __ ]
with that [ __ ] color is if you have a
darker brother or cousin they get made
fun of you have a darker brother cousin
they get made fun of it my youngest son
and daughter mother's Puerto Rica and so
my best friend has a boy his ex-wife he
was born Rica so he go you know portrait
like women are crazy that stereotype
they crazy so is that just is that a
Latin thing with women across the board
[ __ ] really yeah Mexican women ain't
Wow crazy I don't think all of them are
I think it's how you grew up how you are
how you look crazy what when you meet
that too though I mean I and what's
crazy she threw a knife at you happen to
one person and that person yes did I
know Mauricio and he lives in Miami in
his Colombian he goes nah man I ain't no
[ __ ] Mexican women man they [ __ ]
crazy man but this was a fell asleep he
cheated lady his cheating his chick oppa
/ slice open a jalapeno and just [ __ ]
left or input like couldn't
half and put the seed part in his mouth
bro while he was sleeping just a bird
that beats hot grits let's see I think
you answered the question right there
though I think it all depends on what
her what that woman's man has driven her
to you know any woman enormous embrace
so maybe they're more vocal about it or
they're more passionate about it I mean
I would race to like Mexicans they've
said like you know racist or whatever I
think it depends on the degree of where
the [ __ ] you are if you're a Mexican cop
you probably say the n-word if you've
been to prison you probably see that in
or but I don't think all Mexicans are
races against black people or say [ __ ]
no not at all no no and listen I as far
as I'm concerned somebody on our parent
can ask us would you have a problem with
Latin saying the n-word in Brazil they
punished a donde from a poverty
standpoint and getting [ __ ] up from
the police standpoint we suffer some of
the same helmets that's true so I would
be I would be quicker to lay them say it
right and some white dude who's saying
it yes he wants to be down but when you
get when you get someone who's Hispanic
and looks like me and I say it that's a
whole different story
well yeah because of you and you look
like you know jewelry [ __ ] yeah same
time I see if you add that er element to
it or it's a little bit more chiller but
I mean we've used to say it asked
friends you know the a part right but we
was like [ __ ] please I don't I
don't think that a or er matters it
shouldn't it shouldn't but I know I know
but what I'm I think the whole that I
say colors well I think that people the
Latinos who grow up in those communities
where there's Sacramento the bay area I
think when there's a mixture in their
community but I think that they feel
they have the right to say although on
the East Coast you see more of you see
more of what areas is talking about hey
we're all in the same boat here right we
all deal with the same police issues
societal issues prejudice sort of thing
like there's there's a spectrum but we
all deal with some of that
so but on the west coast it's different
when you come out here the prison system
has messed with the Mexican community's
minds I think and because there's so
much race cliques within these prisons
the prison system over here they come
out hating the other more so then on the
East Coast
on the East Coast I mean you might see
it now but it's not as it's not as much
hatred over there between black and
brown I think the hatred though with
them being in jail has a lot to do when
they're in jail and if you bring it out
in the streets then they bring it out to
their family but that type of racism
isn't the type of or using the n-word as
a kids on the street hanging out with
you know together [ __ ] smoking weed
[ __ ] around work and doing this [ __ ]
yeah you know posted some
institutionalized racism where it's your
[ __ ] survival you get killed if you
don't [ __ ] block your race right now
if you want to see the other word
comfortably I think go to Mexico brother
that's the corner bars
what do you one two hookers at five
Edwards well there's nobody there to be
upset right it's just y'all Jewish [ __ ]
it negotiate
oh no Shannon I negotiate with myself
all the time these three percent Jewish
I haven't percent I'm wonder what 1% I'm
half and a half what's up fool so we got
about the part with the podcast Dean
your podcast um you know I think it's
almost like in the sense of any other
podcast where you know you try to talk
about anything and everything but you
know one thing I don't like is this
moisture this moistness of political
correctness we're in now well so I try
to be as you know
hence the ass the jerk I try to keep it
as honest and as brutal as I can man cuz
I I think that people are getting tired
of all this political correctness and
it's like the Prohibition era with
alcohol fools are madly towards wanna
drink man you can't tell people what
they can and can't say can and can't
fool remember - I met I met bro somebody
call the cops out here to the show next
day the comedian I'm a damn area but
what happened here the joke we say the
other joke waste most of his being a
terrorist jokes but here's a joke we say
is out where somebody middle-eastern
that was oh my terrorist looking people
at when they stayed Iraq
was it only takes one to tell a joke
right and anything another one about
whatever we should get together or
whatever and this lady after the show
and her husband call the police dog joke
yes
Hawaii yeah we are lady they were it was
it was I got arrested at comics in New
York for smacking a bitch's titty loose
you know it was funny it was it was like
for black girls sitting up front and and
they really all had an attitude all
night so they wasn't really paying
attention to the show and at one point I
said some about how much is the bill
they told me what the bill was but
before that I went and I act like I was
gonna high-five her and I smacked the
titty and I said you don't worry about
the bill I'm gonna pay for it and my
girl goes oh no you gon pay you don't
pay so when the show is over and I'm out
selling my merch comedy club manager
comes he goes listen are they call the
cops they waiting on you and you got
arrest you and I I almost spent that
night in jail man for assault right bro
yeah you had it you had to talk to cops
and talk to you talk out of it no no I
think they booked me and eventually I
got our cover my own recognizance yeah
and eventually the [ __ ] got dropped
never did that joke no more that's not
words though that's like your hands on
it listen if Galica can smash
watermelons on you videos
that's almost too safe what if it's not
like a fondle the fumble is it was about
what it would have been one of those
back scratchers with the hand on it back
to Jose happening but what's a hand
connected to okay what are you just
doing that I can understand you know
then charge but I'm glad they dropped
the charge of this [ __ ] it was it
was but they had it they had an attitude
to begin with so I know what you're
saying yeah so much in a civilized
society is you can't do Raj leader right
right right
there's a lot beef and the black black
comedians like beef like you don't they
don't like each other or I don't
I hate performer he's on stage Harry
wells hey but he took a picture with
homeboy this weekend oh yeah that
happened to you yeah oh you know Henry
wells know cuz you couldn't stand the
certain comedian he said he Welsh every
well she's Nana and then he'll perform a
Rickey smiley there but this weekend
this past weekend they did a show with
Mike Epps and there was two of them
together Mike Epps in the middle yeah
beef it was 1010 rappers at one comedian
yeah I'm up my beef days if I even had
any your young over I know beef man you
know I mean people try to make it well
we saw that my name was broke honestly
he didn't get one hit in for no [ __ ] my
homemade whether you prob yeah I was you
know you just said I got knocked down oh
you were coming up and [ __ ] you know
rope-a-dope rope-a-dope but you just a
boss right I don't know if you call it
boxing but I had fantasies fantasy maybe
in a champ in the art pissed somebody
off and making them snap that's all that
happened yeah take it huh well your [ __ ]
yeah but but I mentioned I mentioned
when I tell the story I didn't know dude
I thought he was a friend of Cory's so
he was like this is my man and of you
and I'm quoting my man Russell if you
his man you mommy right right and I
thought that's what we will do but but I
wasn't born yet
yeah I'm off of its emotions room yeah
yeah yeah I'm glad I know I got that
ability man to massage you such a
weighted that's a talent no no yeah man
you could have pressed charges to
identity you said that I liked so much
except that you press charges listen I
did was there was there was two ways to
handle it
and so I handled it what I thought was
the best way to handle it as opposed to
the other way to handle it which could
put me behind bars or get some people
get somebody else [ __ ] up take your
money
you know I'm 44 years old man I got to
make chess-like decisions Cheka
decisions no more man yeah ma'am no
funny babies grass is off first
oh you remember his past life he took
his glasses off that's how everybody
when they look at the video that was the
warning when he just glasses up but he
was behind you he was by he was off he
was more to the side he was on the side
of me when it started but then when he
got up yeah he was he was more or less
mile have you ever have you ever got
into with anybody like in the crowd or
any fight like an actual fight or
anything no well I got punched they
asked off-page but not really not during
the show no big do you know I was
talking to somebody and then I was just
talking somebody by the bathroom
cleaning yeah it was a it was a Daily
Planet back in the days and it is full
rad bro and he he [ __ ] threw a mighty
mouse punch at me bro here I come to
save the day
yeah man okay that's a [ __ ]
emotion right stand up yeah begin a set
of seventeen years yeah I think the
longer we stay around we get a little
bit of everything at some point you know
I don't know if anybody's ever tried to
throw something at you mosh the bottle I
mean really no more than here bro
one that little the first that little
gay laws came into play and it was two
dudes right there and I did some almost
uh first day the way we're on the road
yeah nobody talked about that yeah yeah
and the [ __ ] just said what he
spit on me dog fries oh yeah someone
what the [ __ ] am I gonna do I said
[ __ ] I spit on that one my god I had
a good one dog and I spit right do to
hit him nasty like a egg woo and he
jumped out of the seat grab his [ __ ]
24-ounce [ __ ] Heineken and smashed it
over the guardrail over that tortillas
grab my mother was crazy errors yeah
what I was just sitting there every
lever walking into the club and Willie
Barcena will perform read and there's
dude key reader with his [ __ ] lunch
is lunch pail and grab some chick by the
hair and dragged around the club bro Wow
like somebody told Don Draper his wife
is fooling around at wild coyotes
caveman style you know he took the lunch
break with his lunch pail and rice time
she like a - see what I'm seeing
but you know what man that [ __ ] with
her next week so she was there man I'll
do the rope with dope out in the car
it's what happened to do did anything
happen or nothing but they kicked him
out he wanted his money back they give
him his money back but then I went back
on stage and go man I try to like
[ __ ] through a joke and I just told
the odds man I was [ __ ] scared they
don't deal with hecklers man y'all get
him a lot drunks are just people that
are just you you get them every now and
then but people that are just super
[ __ ] drunk someone have a bad back
and forth like I'm doing my shore
doesn't got a dick but they love you
right it's not it's not to be [ __ ] up
it's the only reason it got the balls to
say that's really fun then they do the
[ __ ] from back in the days
oh that's one 45 minutes the end but I
just back it giving and you do you
haven't thrown out or you just just do
it there for a while then they pass out
that they wake up again but then nobody
the people who do this during there
there was a big crowd you know that they
brought seventeen people it's his
birthday
birthday or this guy's a big fan who's
introducing ten people to me but this
was cool about it cuz he's doesn't he's
not like security get him out right now
you know it's not Joey bro
but then I just creep up from behind go
a dog that's enough dude we have Joe
Quimby she's a people or a joke or like
he asked the community for a man who's
loud rose which would love would say
what's that she can walk the crowd it's
afraid of somebody sneezes he gets mad
if he gets mad at waitresses drop checks
you know that's what happens during the
headliners know in this Affairs a
comedian some comedian have a precise
set that they just cannot sway from or
jump off and talk like the love master
but the love master Direction maker yeah
they're the precise set you know like he
may know it so I think there was joke or
some comics there were a set later they
go to how often do you veer off page if
I'm in the wrong town like comedy magic
club everything was going smooth so I
said that I whatever I said this town I
say you know whatever bad but you know I
stay you know Barstow the [ __ ] town it's
a [ __ ] ton before Las Vegas so I said
it's like San Pedro and [ __ ] whatever
it likes that Pedro and and I'm her more
Simon half of the crowd were for [ __ ]
stampede
so they all stood up and started yelling
so I do look laughing locality jokes now
about that he to get a back right now
person should be with yellow your
favorite be their favorite bits of your
show you know Dublin's that fact we was
never so bad but you know on the road
they do that [ __ ] you know and and but
the good thing is they do it towards the
end of my set so now I can kind of give
you the okay fine but if I'm in a you
know trying to do what I'm doing then
that's when it's like a pain in the ass
you like a party animal let your legs
down like crazy like joy a couple of
beers and
that was a devil I've always always
beautiful [ __ ] we do video games yeah
that's your advice let's go you're late
video game video games we do [ __ ] man I
just you know I get terminated a vision
and if I go to a party that's not so
much about the music and the dancing I'm
I'm [ __ ] I'm trying about sticking it
yes yes you're like I got a I got a I
got a sex problem you know what you say
like when you see a chick that you know
how to spot about like gum like iceberg
slim oh yeah that [ __ ] right there
decoder ring just just you know I just
never force it you know if it feels
right it feels right if it if I can play
a little bit of tongue tennis with them
and get my serve their sexual huh back
in the day would you go down and change
it just met or no no no no no your B's
no no no no going down on the chick you
got to be special oh okay everybody
can't get that you know I got an
acquired taste
sorry oh pass oh sorry sorry
[Laughter]
tosspot oh my god yeah man you know and
I'm not even a big fan of bleep I bro
well you toss it when you got a big day
[Laughter]
yeah and I'm not even a big fan of women
going down on me
I like it give me just enough to get
right I'm [ __ ] appetizer I like the
meal gotta be down don't put in all that
work get me right and I'm good you got a
light bulb itself yeah I'm not what I
used to be I'm like an old athlete I'm
ice in the knees now the jerseys about
to get hung in the RAF hilarium
ice enemies baby hey what I used to be
you know well I used to have a rule like
I would never go on the road and bring
something with me I had to have a fresh
piece every city I got these last four
years I'm like man give me a [ __ ] I can
take with me I don't have to fight in me
no more I'm just no no I'm not on the
prowl I used to be you know I make my
meat last longer put in the freezer yeah
he puts it in he puts it in a freezer
bro there never was a little hoof a
little piece yeah little slice yeah
there we go there was a cup of tea you
mentioned all these named Bill Bellamy
you know all these people a lot
competition bro how'd you how'd you pick
it out but you got Bill Bellamy there
you got [ __ ] Eddie Griffin you got
all these big stars in schauberger right
that cowboy hat go home feel how he did
the hat off boy song you know um you
know I never even really looked at it um
like like it that in terms of a
competition I just look at some of the
guys who I have so much respect for who
I know are beasts in the game and I go
how can I be that good
you know she Pels a monster Patrice
O'Neal was a monster so I just I just
want to be able to say I can at least
match that or come close not not trying
to be better than you know I mean just
just want to be considered one-off work
you were serious blonde CBS was that
dude I'm from the [ __ ]
right troubles don't sit brought over
that show I was telling my wife black
like a blonde oh we were watching the
ego's documentary no one man far from
you he had a [ __ ] with every spirit
of [ __ ] they were supposed to be like
Miami Vice yeah yeah like more like oh
yeah yeah yeah and uh who's that like
Butchie like when they got you the deal
you're excited you know I got the whole
school going you know I said to him on
our podcast I came along at a time where
they would give it out remember
development deal you please tell you
that I used to lock you up to take you
off the market so I don't get you hold
you were holding deals so late Friday
buckle style yeah so for the first five
years of my career in LA I had one year
holding deals with every network in town
so I probably made over a million
dollars before I was 21 million but
he'll give no give me a hundred thousand
seventy five thousand yeah dummy row to
is like oh I went like seven years
they pay me another work yeah they pay
you not to work because you want to work
but they basically paying you not to
work in hopes that they create something
for you survive that honey created that
show for you well it just so happened
that that show was already being created
and at the time I saw my deal with CBS
they signed me on first then they signed
on Glenn Frey and we just got [ __ ] man
cuz when we aired we were up against the
number one show at the time which was
home improvement and then also up
against Melrose Place
so the one in the number one show and
then the hottest show and then on top of
that there was the California brushfires
so we didn't even air in California at
all and Glenn Frey was such a nightmare
for the for the network that they just
cancelled us after one show so we shot
13 episodes and they mixed us after one
show and at that time dude I was what
was I was like 18 years old and I was
probably clocking 45 grand a week and it
was it was sweet and it was a it was a
bitter end man but uh it was what it was
look there Fred doing you know when he
first started to show he wasn't the
greatest actor so they wanted to be
though he wanted to be so halfway to
Miami Vice right
so in halfway during the season and he
got better so he didn't want the first
couple episodes to air because he was
that bad so he got in a fight with the
network like eels don't air him let me
shoot him they said we already paid all
his money we're gonna air him and they
had a tug-of-war and it got nasty
so it got so nasty that it was like you
know what you got killed in the ratings
cuz a home improvement and [ __ ]
Melrose Place
you didn't even air in California it's
not worth the trouble and they canceled
us after the first first episode man
how's the show because something I are
in California that's what I'm saying
yeah yeah so humble it was a Jerry
Maguire too though right yeah he played
he played like an agent I think so some
sports GM or something like that yeah
nice God oh I mean he gave me my first
LA Lakers floor seats
[ __ ] Eagle Road yeah man nice dude
don't lie just in the wood huh
what did I just hit right in the wood
it's wild man it's intoxicating
I said I said no I don't know floor
brother for though we're be able then
you'd feel the same it could be the chat
pod game I was sitting down right behind
the photographers Dyer like his thigh
was right here almost makes you feel
they only have seized rather than a
floor right what some of the real bad
you'll get no Feeny bro every Spears and
Rick Rubin I liked it are you big
Sopranos man Norma Sopranos okay I'm a
Sopranos who you know cuz I said who
yeah and I think I'm gonna mining myself
up to do this I don't have you heard it
Sopranos podcast yeah part of being on a
Bing yeah I think we're gonna do the boy
from Miami next week yeah oh no two
comics do it right yeah I think so yes
on the East Coast and I must say I tell
people I'm proud of it my own both
complete DVD sets box collections of my
two favorite shows the Sopranos know
where the exhale flex in the city get
the right JJ
I wanna god I watched every episode of
that show
I watched it when it aired the first
time my dream team and no team big I
know but I I have to root for the woman
and she shouldn't be going back to the
man wrapped her whole world and up in
here's my question for you who was the
bigger [ __ ] and who would be who
would you be most intimidated by Richie
a prio or Ralph Cifaretto
Richie Aubrey oh no I want to see Ralph
because Ralph isn't predictable
Rothberg even taking up the ass really
hard you want to buy that fear bro a
Priora more of like he goes with the
business tradition right okay that's why
wealthy because that's what you'd cure
nowhere bro like I don't know where like
it'd be laughing it and I made that you
nice big roll you out spider style no
one's putting Beau and Ralphie killed
that chick in their [ __ ] bar like
what I was thinking right he killed that
she's you're pregnant right away that do
the monkey need all-out me dirty little
doodoo the toupee wasn't named 18 [ __ ]
uh the guitar player from Bruce so still
he goes he goes you [ __ ] you
killed her she's totally for those tits
now you owe me yeah dog mmm [ __ ] how
could you be a dude in that like
Sopranos really Italian ah dude you
can't [ __ ] with that show and it got
better
Oh the only episodes I did not like what
a dream sequences I'd like to dream I'd
like when the fish is talking to him
like his it's like I would kind of bug
dude because it was like kind of added a
comedic element 2 and then no went home
boy got you know when he got shot those
were kind of you know yeah that person
but even later on when a Tony got shot
well in the dream sequence man and I
don't know who inject right in was a
chaser right whoever I look it was that
was a little trick we got rid of the
Romans didn't we
you're looking at him speaking of HBO
shows and maybe you guys can answer this
question cuz I've been begging for an
answer
can somebody explain to me what the big
[ __ ] deal of Game of Thrones is I was
never into Joe Barone try to give me you
to watch it but one day I watched an
episode and it hit me man and I just
watched the last line I think it's great
I can't get past the dragons everybody
everybody can say the same thing you
have to watch you can get past the first
two or three seasons no I'm a hater with
all that [ __ ] my baby moms sad to get me
to watch that and I tried so hard and I
know it's such a hot show you're
supposed to like it I like it
oh god I can't stand I I've watched it I
got into it for like three episodes and
then it was just so easy not to watch it
again yeah that's what you had me watch
one episode I think and I was like I
don't ever need to watch this again and
I remember what happened just want to
bend the knee no I'm not what I like
reality real life I don't know what's
gonna happen because I seen enough
YouTube videos of my body but every the
top five actor is sure they make half a
million dollars per episode on Game of
Thrones yeah I didn't know across ten
million in episode and to make SNL
sketch custom Ilya has a million-dollar
budget Wow each sketch sketch I would
just like a sketch there you are Matthew
even already lag was there no I came on
third season he was the first Bobbili on
the show to me people put itself yeah
yeah that was a regular thing with him
that was funny you and Bobby or that he
wore you got there um well I was there
from season 3 to about 11 okay yeah yeah
so and Bobby came a little bit later
oh he was after you he was a train wreck
man he was so nervous and he was on
whatever he was on and
he lacked a lot of confidence so uh yeah
he eventually got to where he needed to
be but it was it was difficult at first
he's turned his whole life for him yeah
he ain't got no love for me he thinks I
thinks I hate him and so now he hates me
that's so [ __ ] ridiculous
so it was Game of Thrones so did you
want to be comedian what was you talked
about wanting to be like up there with
Chappelle and Patrice O'Neal and all
that stuff did you when you came out
here and you were acting and you were
getting all this work were you thinking
this is what I want to do more the
acting stuff or did you really still
have that love you know I wanted my
blueprint to be exactly what Eddie
Murphy's blueprint was I wanted to a
sketch comedy show for a couple of years
and have that audience follow me from TV
to film and then never look back I had a
lot of side streets on the way and a lot
of dead ends so I'm still on some paths
but we'll see what happens that's sighs
gee bro I got stuck at a coda site for
many years back to though you're 80
years old man yeah on top of the world
when it would happen right after that
CBS show um another show you know I ass
holding deal ended up being with Fox
so after almost a year of doing nothing
again I did a pilot that was kind of
like the Mod Squad produced by Aaron
Spelling so is exactly like the Mod
Squad black cop white cop white girl
that didn't go nowhere and then by the
time that was almost over
Matt's MADtv was coming into season
three and I auditioned for for season
one and they wanted me then but I was
locked in his deal so the head of Fox
was such a big fan of mine he just told
the producers at MADtv put him on just
put them on and I was on yeah did you
lose a lot of good opportunities when
you were locked down in these deals um
in limbo movies some movies yeah like I
supposed to do a role in the movie twins
which is what's a [ __ ] and DeVito damn
and I couldn't do it they wanted me Bill
Duke the director of Sister Act two
wanting me couldn't do it so I lost
maybe a couple of movies a couple of TV
gigs at one point some people from
Saturday Night Live called me but Lauren
Michaels has a thing where he was like
look if you was on any other sketch show
can't do this one so yeah
bad timing man magician for SNL I just
sent a video then call back did you
really send a video that's when they
were looking for a Latino two years ago
before Melissa gana did you do any
characters or impressions I did two
impressions and then they wanted
original characters what was the other
what was the impressions James
Gandolfini and was and what I did now
where's your original what was the
original Bowen pull yeah I was doing I
was working on it for like a couple
weeks I can't really do it now I saw him
running around the park and what is it
like and here's the thing oh yeah that
was it though he was chasing his kids in
Washington Square Park the other day
reload it no generation of family knows
yeah like little kids it's really the
other daughters sold everything I don't
I don't want to be cheesy this is gonna
come off cheese go for it um but because
I don't do this impression much I try to
want to squeeze it in there so people
know I could do it cuz people always
associate me with jay-z DMX and rappers
yeah but uh Paul Mooney imma let you set
me up Paul's here Felipe asked question
what's up Paul Mooney I already used to
write for Richard Pryor I read every
book if [ __ ] everybody knows I wrote
for Richard Richard was a genius I
didn't always write for respite Aldrich
I gave Richard Clues and Richard would
take them but nobody needs it right for
Richard that is Richard was his own
genius I heard that uh well that
favorite line um chief so far so his
daddy's day with one of your lines he
gave you a watch for it this isn't true
negative is not true Richard and I were
at a party and someone saw a bad [ __ ]
and I said that [ __ ] is so fine I'd
suck a daddy's dick it was in
conversation that was taken out of
context
the morning he was a bully to his bro
from his daddy you're pacing of your
words Oh Paul Paul is all very you know
yet when he talks the thing about Paul
is [ __ ] you have to find your rhythm
yeah and you make those faces those
white [ __ ] know [ __ ] you know
I've seen you one of many rooms probably
one of the guys I work with them he told
her that one night that um we weren't
we're smoking weed and he told her that
out you sent him to Target to buy a
bunch of our white Hanes t-shirts and
then you stole him at the end of the
show you just wrote Paul Mooney on them
I and exactly they were they were white
because now it was mentions to sell some
white [ __ ] that's what I do I buy white
and sell that white like white folks old
[ __ ] you bought us and you sold us get
me a hundred white t-shirts I'm gonna
put my black name on them and sell them
white t-shirts I used to call you miss
thing Richard called everybody pissed if
he called Robin Williams mistake that
was his thing what's up by the podcast
yes Spears in steinberg aka the Jew in
the jerk available at iTunes Apple
Spotify Spears Berg calm or Google Play
that Berg with an ear you are g.com yeah
I didn't I didn't even know it was
pictures ever Michael Michael Collier
was posting data I know he was there
though he's not in great
you came in saw areas where Tommy tease
ya Tommy tease give me some [ __ ] time
of funny that's funny
whose idea was it to do to put you in a
thong on your special and do that little
music video that was mine I don't think
Aires to do such a hateful relationship
with where rap music is now take that
swing get it right yeah yeah every time
I'm here laying somewhere and let's hear
for that we have the photo of you the
little box you stand up other photos and
you always grab that one you listen you
know that big nope I was at that time
well I did I did that photo shoot when I
was more like Lavelle Crawford so I
didn't like you knows photos Larry
Holmes got that nice flat top though so
my [ __ ] was all small yeah like you're
labelled dumb who grew up in New York in
New Jersey exit 9 Brunswick yeah you
Brunswick throw the stress factory yeah
who was it with this Oh Johnny Roque no
no no the older Oh Vinny was just on TV
he was of TMZ he wasn't a big baby Davis
oh yeah what sort of a sellout show he
today was there
yeah because really were still in your
parish
the announcement yeah yeah because in
the announcement he said the measurement
today he said nobody you know I didn't
you know if any likes to give the
announcements in the beginning right and
he said now make sure none of you yell
out like ariana grande or whatever his
other chick's name was no oldest I don't
know the last one Kate Beckinsale
whatever they don't yell out any of
those names so he heard that and was
like he's not supposed to mention those
names I don't want him mentioning like I
guess his person his rep wasn't there to
let Vinnie know don't mention the names
then he decided to let the audience know
not to mention those names but he put it
in everybody's heads and Pete was gone
don't mention my name I wish it when you
can just walk out of a sold-out show
worried about consequences and
repercussions I guess you've reached
another level of Fame got that [ __ ] you
money hey man oh my god you were done
there before they saw the audience vote
man no I've been on stage and had an
audience so [ __ ] terrible that I
wanted to walk off YouTube never done
that I walked up into yeah checked way
to [ __ ] out well I'll do it on my bids
and I just won that did yeah and I'm
gonna do a set man yeah I know you're
talking [ __ ] I'm not gonna give you a
shout out sorry I hate when they walk up
to you out before the show man I hate
seeing the audience before the show so
they want to ask you stuff hey ma'am my
wife is pregnant man you mention it what
everybody went crazy for it so you don't
like to you go straight to the greenroom
and yeah I'm the opposite I thought you
the back to the show though he walks
around before the show come to see me
I wonder my one like prison I want the
baddest [ __ ] in the yard so I
know who the shank [ __ ] so they know to
leave me the [ __ ] alone
I love looking at the crowd before a
show sizing them up this [ __ ] shouldn't
have that on this [ __ ] drunk
that's gonna be a problem
my mom attack this [ __ ] i watch game
tape baby a little bit not too loose
yeah yeah but you get like 10 emails
before the show Hayes our anniversary
it's so and so's birthday give them a
shot like you're supposed to remember
all these people's things
I was just tell people no I won't do
that I know we don't but I'm just auras
are here but Willie I don't like it when
people come up to you Nick oh uh are you
gonna be funny you here ain't you
you know what it is or their friend at
this before this guy was a big fan and
he's a jeweler he saw juice and he
everybody for his friends and it's for
friend least I'd like to play like make
me laugh so just sat there and I laugh
to get a friend man but early at the end
they told me man you were funny man but
we wanna show it to him I'm not part of
your birthday party come on [ __ ] to
jack off to the same porno come on
enough with carmella beam I see him at
the t-mobile one time this is about five
years ago though she was too all right
your phone number she saying your
personal video so you were back in the
day back page back page used to be one
of those dude you could do that she
don't Craigslist back in the days where
jewel will get high and heckle them we
were a 20-3 we crank call them before
[ __ ] that's your big yeah messed up
using that myth
I thought math was supposed to make you
smaller yeah but I mean titties is
gorgeous so how do you know her Playboy
we did we used to do Bible study
together shown or the Romans that
question came out of jealous Hussein
used to call women Eagle Isaac we
haven't spoken over
yes or to Broadway just nude pictures -
no I just I'm down to what I just Bobby
Rose just my girl I'm a single unit just
with my girl that's why his girls like
when I'm on the road with him because
they know that I'm supposed to be the
one to balance everything I don't work
somebody Atkins can Aries tell the story
about how he got Joe Diaz on MADtv well
man you always give you a rock yeah I
never I didn't have anything to do
already listen if you're no Joey tell us
the [ __ ] I'm trying to hook up
with a man oh no I just talked him they
said they [ __ ] give you okay now I'll
definitely lose yeah yeah do you [ __ ]
yeah dude
he says come back from New York just
break down you miss your name bro he
said it to a couple times to us if you
can believe it was slobbering nasty oh
yeah water coming out his mouth bro I
thought he was Italian nobody cooks
Cuban II was raised by an Italian family
after it's not a doctor okay I'll go
check out that a video on youtube I know
it's too hard I got my boss we produced
yes okay like I said the room had all
the [ __ ] way is chasey they were
running out of room spare a [ __ ]
press you can follow what tell you
[ __ ]
Kanan wanted to adopt them [ __ ]
and then I met his mother his mother his
mother was at my mother's bar
we're basically [ __ ] brothers like
Quincy should veto any after parties
after our parties out here in our lair
[ __ ] dude I'm telling you man my days
I'm 44 I've really don't have it in me
no more no joy you know even when I come
home from doing stand-up he's always
egging me on to go to the store and go
to the heart and I just once I'm on the
road so much so when I'm home I'm done
you know rest I'm done man
I'm 54 though you should be able to keep
up I know I'm 47 he keeps talking about
how 44 like it's 64 or something I gotta
give my second wind okay I'm like a
molested child in show business
I haven't recovered yet you better the
mansion the playboy man yeah it's Weiss
[ __ ] bananas first time first time I
went I went for the 4th of July party
which is the creme de la creme second
time I went I did Tom liked us he was
doing a party there I'm like Tom like us
but both times it was it was bananas
where it's everything you thought it
would be everything yeah so we were
there we had a burn victim a charity
event it was for these guys they got
blown up and warriors and um there was a
guy there who are without a donation he
speaks to their wounds rolling he gets
pieces of other people to pass I think
surgery
Congrats yeah
ask tissue tissue so what would you do
about the madtv what you hopped on uh
you know I had about a year off and then
I did learn the road world trip no not
really I did the road for about a year
and a half and then I did the
underground with damon wayans his sketch
show which lasted a season and then
after that I became a road warrior man
sprinkled with a couple little movies
here and there the pest was John
Leguizamo and movie with LL and you know
a little bit of stuff here and there but
you know you do a little impression yeah
everybody not everybody but I mean
everybody doesn't do a good honor
yo what's bananas me it's crazy man
got a album dropping surreal sexy y'all
know what sex is like do you mix it with
water man I can't work I can't wax on
your chest let it melt down your nipples
and your neighbors that's crazy be super
ganas me yeah at least I'll braid her
hair right now Vig what the [ __ ] is live
right here bedford-stuyvesant the
Labatt's one thought you heard mother
[ __ ] of the turns she liked me baby
oh they be the rappers cold like the
shivers talk slick [ __ ] came is vicious
malicious how about all do you like a
cancer doc speak bleep talk about the
chances biggie baby
Jeremy don't know never met big
what the person of you men in your life
like that said everybody say oh my god
Michael Jackson nice aw Michael at the
Shrine Auditorium for the American Music
Awards one year but never never met him
you know the only people I've ever
wanted to meet the Michael Jordan never
met him I met Muhammad Ali which was
mind-blowing and Eddie Murphy was that
Eddie Murphy coolest thought it was
weird I don't know how long you've been
in LA but back when that place used to
be called the Roxbury yeah yeah hottest
club in town I was there one night and I
was up in the top Eddie Murphy walks in
with his bodyguard and they go sit in
the corner and I knew it was Eddie
because when he came in he was smiling
he had shades on of course but when he
smiled I saw a little baby teeth a
little mini TV I walked over I told that
story on Conan and I don't think he
liked that
Chucky Betty snap so that was my brief
encounter with uh Eddie you know that's
a rock paper when now what's the name
punch Tom Charlie Murphy huh nobody ever
punched Charlie Murphy out oh that whole
uh you mean TK Kirkland no what's it
about the game what the [ __ ] man okay
yeah that was the Rick James story to
get Coakley no we never had him you're
right no I kind of ignored it
CK us/uk yeah you know some stories
behind did you warn the big Def Jam tour
after the show you know we did the first
of the lip a well yeah at first but you
know at that time it was more about the
exposure cuz Def Jam was such a
phenomenon and it was huge def that
second year which is when I did Def Jam
the tour was me adele givens Reggie
McFadden Bernie Mac Ivan broke
[ __ ] enough your last stop was at
Madison Square Garden where I got booed
off stage mercilessly really that walk
and my hotel was in Times Square but
anywhere in New York is quick when you
walk because it's such blocks that walk
back from the garden of my hotel felt
like I was Bill Bixby in the Hulk you
know what I tried to do a joke I didn't
I didn't prepare for the right way like
the thing I did that eventually went on
YouTube that went viral and got 14
million hits where I do all the rappers
rapping I just tried to wing it
I didn't pay it the proper respect I
didn't I just tried to wing it I'm not a
rapper so it was horrible and then when
I said okay I need to go in the lab so I
really wrote the rhymes down and got the
impressions and the mannerisms and the
cadence down and then when I did it at
that radio station in San Francisco
that's when it boom and it took off yeah
but I just it was bad how bad blow like
I wasn't [ __ ] that night oh that
movie called I'm dying up here though we
did about bombing I'm dying
No yeah I'm dying up here I'm dying up
here yeah no it was dying laughing dying
laughing are they committed to a bar
talk about our bombing what was it like
to was bombing feel like to you it's
just
it starts off slow huh I hate to say it
it's a it feels like suiciding well you
wanna die well you just feel like you
know holy [ __ ] and even when you have
when you don't bomb but you're just not
getting from the crowd what you normally
get you question everything mark this
drive I've been doing this 30 years and
I'm like yo it's like maybe you got 30
years of work you don't put your time
and of course you should be doing but
all it take is one bad show and you want
to redeem yourself immediately
I ain't never box professionally but I
always said this must be where the
fighter feels when it's like after 30 a
no record and he'd get that first loss
you gotta get back in that ring you want
that win again so to feel there's an
internet again oh yeah yeah
I deal might have subscribe that bombing
and that it feels like a real Bombay man
a real Barbie man I just think with you
for three days man it stays with you
until you get back on stage you'll be
laying a bad man to get about your
finances I don't know if that's true for
money day maybe I'm a resident should I
take these furniture back to register
yeah can be Bobby with nobody hurts more
huh well I've been fortunate enough to
you know grab a little bit of a cushion
that's been right but nonetheless but
mental bubbles you know like I feel I'm
performing I feel like I killed but I
feel like same odd it was the same style
all in the last audience but these
[ __ ] laughs loud and some first
audience but then I thought like I
mentally bar like I said just took the
wrong way today or something yeah it's
not it sucks when you feel like you you
poured your heart and soul into a bit
that you wrote planned and somehow it
just didn't the audience just didn't
feel it the way you meant it to be felt
but then other times you'll be on stage
and winging it and something kills
incredibly hard like that yeah for that
[ __ ] to do that like so you know it's
tricky yeah it's tricky the worst the
worst bottom I ever had actually was
here and a tall Hispanic lobe and when I
don't even remember what it was and this
is I said room
yeah it was years ago it was it was
probably about five or six years ago and
I'm Mexican and Jewish and I don't like
to I don't like people to know I'm at
ski until I tell them I'm Mexican the
first thing they did is introduced me as
met ski to do it's a bad thing we've
seen this [ __ ] and I went up there
and they're like no I just doing it and
all he did is look at me like yes
just [ __ ] hurt that one hurt that one
that hurt because I thought all of this
is gonna be fine out here right it was
my first time out in LA and it was just
the worst week that I had probably ever
had in my life
you can be an old white dude or I'm not
saying you're like great you can but you
can kill in a black Club or a Latino
Club when he has chuck bartowski's he's
67 your Brown is brown these guys are
both on their 60s they've been doing
comedy for years and they have this
weird dry dark humor and they kill the
audience isn't expecting so it's always
a surprise that all that who is that
always always one who is George
Washington cuz you always thought but
they'll always ask afterward and these
guys have no social media barely what
Larry barely has one I do thanks but mom
I just I just feel about the whole Bill
Cosby T when it came out your walkable
right for a little while not really I
mean you know it doesn't change his body
of work
he doesn't change did the greatness of
what he's done nobody getting back those
scholarships back but you know we saw
him stuff new South perform at 3 p.m. in
San Antonio as I write yelp doing the
rivers in a comedy club majestic great
yeah majestic theatre we were except for
about an hour and 35 minutes than I left
this will got a ticket and I snuck in
focused look here brother intermission
we have to know the first 10 minutes of
his uh of the performance because they
had the you know they they uh sure you
to sit you down and then they came out
the side door because I was trying to
figure out a way to get in but I
couldn't get into the front cuz they had
security and cops was this was so
[ __ ] the ushers came out to smoke a
cigarette the [ __ ] door flung open I
was like
you met Tyson yeah couple times he might
now cuz he's found his function
yeah he seems like humble when I first
impersonated him on the best damn sports
show I was nervous as [ __ ] and he kind
of it was almost like he's looking at
you and you feel like you're looking at
an Unchained lion it could go wrong it
might not but it could go wrong so you
know he kind of gave me that look where
it was like okay okay
but yeah intimidate do man human pit
bull
you were an original cast member on that
show the Porsche
not an original they had me on for like
two months straight because at first I
did like a couple of guest spots and
they really did well so they was like
you'll come knock out the summer with us
so for like June and July I was there
every week with the guys yeah was that
after Jerry Maguire Oh way out yeah Jay
McClaren did your diction for that I
auditioned for Cuba Goodings part what
really hammering crow really loved what
I did but he was like look this role is
too big for you we need a bigger name
but because I like what you did I'm
gonna give you the brother so he gave me
the brother oh hell yeah what Tom Cruise
you talked to him during that [ __ ] or
not you taught her not really but one of
the coolest [ __ ] on the very
cool very cool so goddamn down earth
very sweet man I'm telling you real good
real good dude we're reading this book
all about Don Simpson those same high
commerce high constable are you yeah I
already but I'm still watching Days of
Thunder I've been watching Top Gun I've
been watching all those movies yeah
except for Flashdance haven't watched it
in a long time but so let me ask y'all
something because we again we talked
about this on our podcast now there any
comedians who you obviously have respect
for and
recognize dad see yo he's [ __ ] funny
but he just doesn't do it for you like
like I can look at and I don't want to
sound like some hateful [ __ ] like I
think I get the brilliant
I get the brilliance of Chris Rock I
[ __ ] get it I look at him I watch
them ago God that [ __ ] some
smart
well damn this is oh it just doesn't
make me laugh now that's not to say I
don't think he's funny he just doesn't
make me laugh Dave Chappelle makes me
laugh gut-busting tear jerk jaw her you
know I'm saying does that make sense
that you like like you can recognize the
greatness before bringing the painter
after or it doesn't even matter that new
madam
okay I just I just II just I get it I
[ __ ] get it just what he just don't
know that bring me man yeah yeah you can
see where he's a little stale now but I
mean I don't even want to use that word
because it seems like I'm saying yeah
he's not cuz honey right right right you
know warm yeah there you go never done
it for him he's never done it for him
I'm just saying like if I'm sitting
watching I can go but right right that
guts yeah yeah I don't want to see that
might sound like I'm hating and I'm not
I'm just I'm just certain comics I look
at and I just go oh the big fan of these
I'm sorry
I think [ __ ] that bust me up or
[ __ ] like Corey Holcomb chill
don't know it's kind of a birth first
album yeah but do you know you can I'm
sure you can think of somewhere you go I
know this guy should be should be funny
he's funny to a lot of people and I see
that's a well written joke or whatever
but he doesn't make me laugh like on the
way that show that otherwise we'll do
comedians all John Mulaney and Nick
Kroll yeah that's special I don't get it
everybody likes it yeah but you do you
recognize that that they're good oh
there are good but I was listening to XM
and and I'm listening to Martin Lawrence
and I'm just going oh yeah God just does
it but I know how [ __ ] funny he is
the show is funnier than like he makes
me laugh in movies yeah he has some of
the greatest reactions and
like bad boys he kills me in bad boys
but his stand-up I don't feel for him
what I feel for Patrice O'Neal but
Teresa Alma Ganga this Thunder well I
didn't do that to me I look at Patricia
you had like he didn't get as much
breaks as my Lawrence so Margaret had to
do so much other stuff like learn our
dishes act all the other stuff so it's
comedy you know like Patrice was also
self-destructive you know he was always
the guy to walk in the room and go [ __ ]
you yeah - to the head of [ __ ] you yeah
so you know that's crazy you know it is
but but another level you couldn't deny
his raw ability just [ __ ] raw man
were you there were polar Francisco
audition for the show how about
Francisco um for bad TV he was on there
first I know he was on you're a little
bit rude right there huh no in the first
two years yeah I think so yeah first two
years now who doesn't do it for you dog
huh who doesn't do it for you like I
don't get it it don't say mogera
I mean there there's the reserves a
handful of fools man you didn't mean
that you did it's like wow but everybody
- everybody huffy uh I think Gabriel was
[ __ ] super [ __ ] funny uh that for
the first special when that stuff but
after that I kind of don't get it
anymore
nothing special should be an hour and a
half right yeah well you know that could
be something to it some almost - it's
like all right he is great personality
but it's like it's just not that the
magic is in there for me like it left do
you mean I don't know our first might be
still there or the [ __ ] caricature
but as far as funny funny funny do you
remember those days [ __ ] that one
time when the devil was onstage well and
I even flew those fools don't represent
that much but he was doing a little
[ __ ] that special Casa latina and
then you were with the jacket you know
[ __ ] you know cuz you that's the days
when that [ __ ] was super funny from the
ground up
I don't know just it's not the same
anymore I mean I know I know and you
know [ __ ] gonna look at me
right now and talk [ __ ] or whatever or
whatever they [ __ ] could say but I'm
not trying to be a dick but yeah but
then that's why I brought dinner because
again I feel like this [ __ ] political
bit and again that's why I emphasize I'm
not on some hate [ __ ] right it's not
about I'm just saying if we'd be lying
it if we all sat up here and went
everybody gets a trophy
everybody dessert everybody's yeah
that's not mean ain't no funny together
I don't nobody could creep on Netflix
and grab ten specials out of their gone
I don't understand this right people
don't find the distributing funny but I
thought he was funny like I could just
name it it's probably this whole room
might not buy him funny new hamburger
exactly new hamburger is a comedian he's
an outcome he like you talk about
alternative comedians he's probably on
his first out when out started he was
there first he goes up on stage was say
seven hardcore drinks I'm on him he's a
greasy ass face he looks like a child
molester in a bad suit and he does
horrible jokes are funny to his audience
he does 30 minutes of the worst children
everything in here but this guy can
bring in a crowd of 200 people at a bar
you never heard of either the bar he's
like a bad lounge hacky lounge act type
he's got a character that's the thing
he's been around for longer than me yeah
well I've seen him a couple times very
funny yeah it's all my jobs do like that
yeah and you had a bunch of drinks on
the table
[ __ ] you [ __ ] man did you hear the
one about Rin Tin Tin
you know bad rule well that's that's
almost like what the Andy Kaufman thing
yeah they don't get I get it people will
look at that go genius where a lot of
people I'm like what am I missing man
that's what I'm saying
passed away the movie was good
about Amy Schumer's stuff like I don't
that's another I I hear I see the jokes
and I go okay that should be funny but I
haven't laughed once at this
there's several specials I've been
watching he didn't watch specials but I
watched a lot of specials lately because
we're doing the third special this year
and I've been trying to see what
everybody stages look like and
everything and I can't sit through some
of these I have to turn them off after
20 minutes I don't have enough of her
career to answer I don't know I don't
know I do you like do you like flu shots
though when he does that Skippy green
character have you seen yeah I've seen
the show I get it you know but it's all
character it's an old character like
that involved in the bond oh yeah I love
that Skippy green character I think it's
funny and a lot of people don't get it
they think there's a dial yeah it's a
catch skills oh yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know like there's some people who do
like cholo fear bro yeah and some people
don't like it like cheese Murph teaches
juggle everything I like it but I loved
it yeah he's original one it's a Mexican
with the matter
you know mustache the bean what time you
gotta get out of here Aaron what's up
what's your Instagram people gonna
follow you out
everything is my name Facebook every
spares Instagram every Spears YouTube
every Spears and I know a lot of people
might not be aware of it but patreon
subscribe to my patreon I'm up on that
cameo celebrity shout outs on the cameo
app all my stuff is a terry spears
dot-com for all that information yeah
mine's auntie comedy comm all my
information is the upper right where did
you grow up at Phoenix Tucson actually
do some sides own yeah that's why I
started bro Bugsy's in Tucson yeah that
was a long long long time yeah that's
what they were fluffy last virginity bro
it's funny Joe Diaz was a Joe Diaz was
on podcast so there he's gonna start
telling the story and then he got
sidetracked yeah well that's what
Gabriel lost his virginity in listen to
the one with Thompson on the first like
20 minutes he meant it but then he like
got sidetracked you get mad at him
though of course not what's up fool you
have a right to
so now I just open up for him this is
burrs building right is it burnt paper
and magic
yes Ober has enough money to put on
air-conditioning what the we just got
new headphones last week after you do
you do a burn do you do a burn Joe Rogan
do you talking bro well I find it man
we're gonna discover new stuff what the
[ __ ] you want to go to the moon for
[ __ ] you got a [ __ ] gorilla
biscuit over there you eat it Joey you
don't want to go [ __ ] the moon and [ __ ]
you dogs got the face down you know what
that means this [ __ ] Spanish it means
[ __ ] kisses and you can kiss my dick
we're gonna be at this weekend
Cincinnati attend Liberty Liberty funny
bone there buddy funny bones yeah I say
that I know where I'm gonna be and next
week uh Orlando Orlando no no no you
know one of my favorites that broke when
I do improv Florida baby thank you
taking my son my son's graduating from
high school my little dude through true
chaos Steinberg and we're taking him
with us we're going to Orlando we're
gonna go see always go your where's your
favorite place to perform anywhere in
southern Florida you girls dressed like
you don't like your father's West Palm
Fort Lauderdale my driver in Orlando
Orlando the dude the [ __ ] we're talking
about sniping with George George and
then in July all being me Mommy Florida
baby love me my third Darrell
I haven't I haven't been to Miami of
improv since they left Coconut Grove
yeah yeah yeah yeah 30 minutes from
Miami though isn't it
no yeah yeah with the club right there
yeah okay yes all that as well is really
love it I'll take it
vanish man I'll take it
I'm back I'm on my second divorce right
now three kids my oldest is 20 my
youngest is four
my son is eight four nine baby yeah I
have dogs yeah we might begin another
dog this weekend you do Richard Pryor
position not at all you know not too
much no why was the guard did you do
your dates yet
okay Comedy Store tomorrow night people
Comedy Store sold-out Spanish show
Thursday May 16 are espanol yeah tennis
time do you know about let alone also
man I'm gonna be at the Irvine improv
may 23rd to 26 to the shoulder sold out
already Salinas California posterior May
31st Stockton California the Bob Hope
theatres June 1st Santa Barbara
California the Granada Theater June 7
Alton Texas at the moody San Jose State
National Civic Center June 14 no Orleans
joy theater joy theatre Julie and
there's more a lot of brand-new tour
dates on that tour your whole years
almost how many how many people do those
theaters hold I don't know dependents
some of them are like 2,000 some are 900
like the one in New Orleans is small
that's not his market work
but San Jose is like San Jose like 2600
I think you'll so that uh and um
Stockton and the other one or about it
fifteen hundred I do all right where
every city where the in America where
the stage start with as a and go San
Antonio San Jose Santa Monica and what
we want to do but my favorite ultimate
gig is like not to Hawaii or other
exotic places that luenell goes to in
the past in the Caribbean
I like Portland man porn of the sheets
or linens Hierro Orleans nice but it's
got a nice dirtiness to it that's it I
already feel Oh eating and going
straight to my roots they see a lot of
white boys play ukulele barefoot is the
youngest homeless I've ever seen in my
whole pickle feet right there on
Burnside right why were the taco stands
that yeah I saw a guy there man like
just a regular dude man could it could
be no no older than 39 41 years old hit
a nice jacket
I sleep your bag and you reading a book
bro in the middle of street homeless you
know mmm do I saw this tent and then
this guy comes out kind of ratty looking
and then this like actually good-looking
girl came out of the tent that's like
it's it's good to be homeless in
Portland be homeless if it works out oh
yeah bad like Coachella look you're
homeless it's like the ones in New York
at Tompkins Square Park back when I
lived there in our early 90s to 2000 all
those homeless people were kids and then
they'd go home for the holidays they
leave the city and go back home beg for
money from their parents and come back
but they were all in their 20s what's up
ooh can we shout out this podcast yeah
thank you spirits in Steinberg aka the
Jew and the jerk the jeweler jerk
available through Google Play Spears
Berg comm iTunes / Apple and Spotify
baby oh yeah shoutout to everybody who
came out to vittles just last night in
Riverside thank you
what's up man will do the presentation
before you go yeah what's up do the rap
one bro a rap one what's your favorite
one to do I don't really have a favorite
dude your daughter Shaq
[Laughter]
did you see that when they they clown on
him on April Fool's when they were
showing the best centers the top ten not
to be upset but he was upset I was gonna
tear up this white dude do you still do
your arm your hip hop closer now we were
in a shell did ya do right here bra put
it to bed baby
well do do it do it do you see like do
you feel like when you see your comics
and you hear like any man you see old
Carlos 52 years old you know what
started with you a man he Youngblood oh
I saw somebody doing your jay-z all
together da man listen I tip my hat to
the brothers are doing well Jay Pharaohs
a beast
hey Fionna Crockett's a beast they all
beasts and they all right man you know
and then beloved beloved beloved lovey
what's up fools [ __ ] steamy podcast
who shut out to Arizona as every spirit
we got cheesenut matching me bro you're
late though here we talked about that
[ __ ] I was out late Jeff Dunham
impersonation think WNBA's gonna take my
thirty I do it my desktop impersonation
with no puppies okay there it is worse
so I gotta get how would you post
another podcast what so podcast the
jeweler jerk the jeweler jerk yeah man
thank you very much oh thank you thank
you for having me
also much Trinity mmm best piece yeah